let's say that the economy of country a
is stagnating it's may be facing a
deflationary crisis so central bank
tries to print as much money and lower
interest rates as much as possible and
an investor can go into country a and
borrow na s currency at a 1% interest
rate let's also say that in the rest of
the world and in particular in country B
you one can actually make relatively or
what you perceive is safe investments at
a higher interest rate in company in in
country B's currency and so let's say
that you can get a 5% return so you can
imagine some opportunistic investors
might say wow I could borrow in country
a s currency and so let's say they go
into country a they borrow at 1% in
particular they borrow they borrow 100
and I won't call them dollars or yen's
I'll call them or anything or euros or
anything else I'll call them 100 s where
the the name of a currency is an a so
they borrow a hundred a's and let's say
the the the conversion rate is at right
now at this point in time one a is equal
to 2 b's so they go into currency
markets and then they exchange it for
everyone a they get 2 b's so they get
exchange it for 200 B's they exchange it
for 200 B's and then they go and invest
it they are investing in B's so this is
their borrowing and a's their borrowing
and a's and they are investing in B's
and so what would happen well they're
going to get 5% on their money and B's
so 5% of 200 they're going to get 10 B's
let's say that's per year so they're
going to get 10 B's in interest every
year and then they can convert that they
can convert those 10 B's if we assume
the exchange rate holds constant and
that is a big assumption they can
convert that to 5 a's based on the same
exchange rate and so that will be 5 a's
5 days but they only have to pay one a
and interest so let me divert some over
here so they only have to pay one a in
interest and so they're just going to
get four a's they're going to get four
a's per year if we assume constant
exchange rate they're going to get four
a's a year for free assuming that they
could continue to do this and then they
could take those four a's and convert
them to B's or whatever other currency
want so they could just you could say
they're getting four A's for free every
year or they're getting eight B's per
year every year and this little process
this little trade this little perceived
arbitrage that's going on right over
here this is called the carry trade this
is called the carry trade and you might
think about well where where would this
break down
well the main area where this would
break down is while you are borrowing an
A and then investing in B if a is
currency appreciates if a is currency
appreciates or especially relative to B
is currency because then what happens
even though you have this interest rate
discrepancy and even though you feel
like you're getting a lot of 10 B's
those 10 B's are going to give you fewer
and fewer A's if a keeps appreciating or
another way to think about it is you're
going to in terms of bees even though
you think you only owe 1% interest a is
also going to appreciate so in terms of
bees you're going to owe more and more
bees every year if a appreciates now
what's worked out in the carry trade or
at least the most famous of the carry
trades we're in starting in the mid 90s
people started borrowing in Japan
because they had low interest and then
investing other places like the US and
especially other places like Iceland is
that the more people do this so you can
imagine if a lot of people keep doing
this and it becomes kind of a big herd
effect what happens you have a bunch of
people borrowing an A and then
converting it to B so they're taking
this currency and converting it to the
magenta currency and if that happens
then you actually have the opposite
effect then you get a benefit on top of
the interest rate discrepancy because
that means the demand for B's currency
goes up and demand for a s goes down and
this is essentially what happened
relative to Japan and a lot of the rest
of the world when Japan had its lowest
lower interest rates all the way until
really about 2008